today I'm going to start with two
different stories about Challengers to
Joe Biden and Donald Trump respectively
in their 2024 primaries for Joe Biden
the Democratic primary for Donald Trump
the Republican primary we're going to
start with some really interesting clips
from an interview that Fox News
propagandist did last night with Bobby
Kennedy Jr Robert F Kennedy Jr who's
running as a democrat in the Democratic
primary challenging Joe Biden now I
don't know whether I need to rehash My
overall view about Challengers to
incumbent presidents running for
re-election but to be 100 percent clear
I support challenges to incumbent
presidents Joe Biden doesn't have any uh
particular claim to the Democratic
nomination just because he's an
incumbent anybody who wants to run
against him should I would like like to
see debates I get why the DNC isn't
going to do them because why would you
ever
put your uh current president from your
party in a position where they can
really only damage themselves and I
understand why the DNC isn't going to do
debates it's not unique to the
Democratic party it's not unique to Joe
Biden it's not unique to 2024. that
being said the current Challengers to
Joe Biden Bobby Kennedy Jr and Marianne
Williamson are not particularly
impressive to me now before we get to
the interview you have to understand
something
really specific that's going on with
right wing media
and the people challenging Biden right
now meaning Bobby Kennedy Jr and
Marianne Williamson Marion Williamson
was also interviewed by Hannity last
night we're not going to look at that
interview today but maybe we will later
in the week and one of the things you
have to understand
is that Kennedy and Marianne Williamson
are useful to right-wing media as ways
to criticize Joe Biden and to criticize
the Democratic Party
they don't actually find these
candidacies interesting on their merits
the Bobby Kennedy one is interesting
because it's an anti-vaxx candidacy so
that might be one way in which it is
interesting but when Hannity interviews
Marianne Williamson if you look at that
interview there was a whole bunch of
focus on both five six times trying to
get Marianne Williamson to say she
believes Joe Biden is suffering from
severe cognitive decline
it's not because Hannity thinks
Marianne's platform is valuable that
he's having her on he's having her on to
try to get her to attack Biden on
something he wants to see Biden attack
done and similar similarly with Bobby
Kennedy Jr it's not that the anti-vax
actually is interesting but it's just
another way to criticize Democrats and
to attack the DNC okay so that's the
context of why these right-wing shows
are interviewing people like Bobby
Kennedy Jr and Marianne Williamson that
all being said
Sean Hannity asked Bobby Kennedy Jr
since you're an environmentalist
are you swearing off private jet travel
and Bobby Kennedy Jr fails hard
this is an example of what happens when
you're totally unprepared Bobby says and
again remember Bobby's a nice guy I had
dinner with him once we have many
friends in common but I I think the
candidacy is ridiculous I think his
anti-vaxx activism is ridiculous
he first says he is not someone who
regularly flies on plot private jets or
he kind of like I don't fly on the much
totally unprepared and this just looks
terribly this is it looks terribly look
at this you were getting on a private
jet have you given up all use of private
jets of your environmental views I was
literally laughing out loud when I saw
this this morning are you really going
back to that Sean
but that's a simple question did you are
you pledging to never do have you given
up the use of private jets
Sean I don't fly on private jets I don't
regularly fly on private jets I don't
regularly fly on private oh okay I'm not
regular up any use of somebody if
yeah listen I've never objected to
people listen I think this climate
alarmist stuff is a bunch of crap so I
don't care if you do or not but if
you're claiming to be a big
environmentalist you shouldn't be flying
on a private jet right
I'm not that kind of environmentalist
and I he's a private jet
environmentalist guys I have been
fighting for against pollution on the
rivers and water against coal and
pollution against carbon pollution
because of the toxicity of those things
I have not told people that they
shouldn't fly on private jets okay this
is really bad guys this is also so
stupid because listen private jet I mean
all jet the the harvesting refining and
burning of jet fuel
Utes Rivers you know he he's acting like
no I focus on like Dupont leaking
chemicals into a river oh Rivers well
okay what do you think happens with the
production and the burning of jet fuel
all over the country it gets some of it
gets into rivers
this is just it's not serious this is
not this is none of this is serious this
is embarrassing and humiliating and it
is a gotcha from Sean Hannity it is a
gotcha from Sean Hannity but it's one
that you've got to be prepared for you
really have to be prepared for it there
was another moment I want to look at
here
where and remember Bobby Kennedy's
Democratic campaign
is one that is extraordinarily pro-putin
it's conspiratorial it's anti-vaxx it's
a lot of things that the kind of
do I want to call it the regressive left
likes we'll get to that in a moment he
brings up a con totally unfounded
conspiracy theory about what's going on
in Ukraine and by the way what we're
doing in Ukraine is not good for the
Ukrainian people we have killed 300 000
Ukrainian troops 14 000 civilians well
Europe
we have not killed any Ukrainian troops
I'm trying to think what on Earth is he
talking about what could he mean we've
killed 300 000 Ukrainian troops Russia
has maybe I don't know if that's even
the number Russia has killed Ukrainian
troops but only if you interpret this to
mean
the we the U.S
caused induced or forced Russia to
invade Ukraine could you say we have
anything to do with the killing of
Ukrainian troops so this is really
Bonker stuff just the Chaos Agent per
Steve Bannon right the user Steve Bannon
term this is a Chaos Agent and my
colleague John sent me this article this
morning from the new Republic the
article is called who were these
supposed lefties who love Robert F
Kennedy Jr and if you read the article
and if you just look around online you
very quickly realize that even though
he's nominally running as a Democrat
Bobby Kennedy Jr is running a sort of
combination pro-putin
uh anti-us sort of campaign it's
appealing to those folks who are often
in League with people like Bashar
al-assad and Vladimir Putin and the
Maduro Chavez regime of Venezuela and
then it's also people who dabble in
anti-vax people who dabble in
anti-science conspiracy theorists
opportunists Etc it's certainly not a
progressive campaign
um and to even call it a democratic
leaning campaign uh doesn't really make
sense so that's what's going on on the
Democratic side people challenging Joe
Biden and again I say challenge them
bring everybody in everybody should run
run against them okay but that doesn't
mean I have to celebrate and welcome
every individual campaign let's now talk
briefly about the side challenging
Donald Trump one of our sponsors today
is fume not everything in a bad habit is
wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad part from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning device that
does exactly that fume is not electronic
there's no Vapor or harmful chemicals
fume is just a delicious flavored air
that makes replacing your bad habit easy
your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable Parts which is great for
fidgeting which can be great for for
people breaking bad habits look at what
people online are saying they weren't
sure what to expect but ended up loving
the taste and the feel stopping is
something lots of people put off because
it's difficult to do but switching to
fume is easy and enjoyable there's no
reason that you can't be the next fume
success story head on over to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to save 10 when
you get the journey pack which comes
with the device and three flavors the
link is down below